[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum good morning if you're
listening early if you're a early riser
a paul reiser you just feel like you
wanted to listen to my podcast first
thing hear my voice I appreciate that
I'd like that maybe we're the first two
people I'm the first voice you're
hearing I hope I and that'd be pretty
cool um you know I mean it's it's hard
not to you know talk about the elephant
in the room I mean obviously it's been a
little crazy the world's upside down and
I have hope I just I do I'm just gonna
say it stay positive try to love a
little more try to understand um you
know you get sort of in these situations
where you just you start to spiral I've
talked about that I get ahead of myself
I get anxiety and great because today we
have amazing guests guests that I they
prove that therapy works because they
were my therapists one was my life coach
when I went over to a facility Prive a
Swiss and they they don't really they
don't ever need publicity at all they
don't you know I really ask cuz I really
love this place so much that I just said
hey can I talk about it and so um hi
Heidi
thank you my friend Zach Levi good
friend he's been the show a couple times
he's an advocate for mental health you
know he's gonna do an intro here in a
minute I get to talk to him and he went
there and then they talked to me and
finally I figured it out and I had to go
and you'll hear all about that and talk
to these two amazing women Sandi Danyel
and Ellen Wasel who you'll be watching
and listening to are two amazing human
beings who genuinely care and I think
for me it all starts with safety if
you're scared of going to therapy or
you're scared of you know tapping into
the unknown or maybe things that you
know that you haven't tapped into and
you know that you want to just feel
better and be better and have a better
outlook on life it's important to feel
safe and I feel
Prive Swiss gave me that safety I opened
up I was so vulnerable I became a
different person in a good way I mean I
just you know safety is so important and
these two women are phenomenal
hey guys also I say it all the time but
it really helps if you're listening and
you love the podcast you want to keep
hearing it I'd love for you to just send
an email to people or go to our social
media handles follow write a review all
that stuff really helps and I say it all
the time because I want to and I and I
enjoy the show so much and I and I hope
you do and if you are maybe you can
contribute by getting other people to
listen I don't know just a thought I
just want to give everybody my love out
there and say hang in there and you know
you're hearing that every day with the
news and you know it's ah the corona
virus is rising again and there's a
second way well you see these dip shits
on the [ __ ] in the Ozarks and you see
them everywhere and you know people
don't want to wear masks and I'm not
even pull it this isn't political this
isn't politics this is just stupidity
okay I mean if you're listen go away I
think everybody out you know can
understand that it's not even about you
wear a mask so I don't have to get your
[ __ ] just follow the rules my buddy's
like oh man I don't wanna pay anybody I
don't wanna do them like hey what are
you obeying you're saving lives maybe
let's just we're figuring this out
nobody has the exact answers I mean but
I I try to listen to scientist people
who were smarter than me which is a lot
of people I found myself protesting one
day few weeks ago and I had never really
protested per se
and I just you know I just walked and
said hey you know I want to walk with
all these beautiful people were trying
to make change and it was peaceful and I
immediately got [ __ ] emotional I mean
the second I just was with a part of
something that was just trying to you
know it was just it was so important it
just felt it was powerful just to get in
walk with people and and hear their love
and their passion and their their
sadness and their emotions I encourage
you to feel when you're watching on TV
and you're seeing these
yeah I don't think you understand as
much get out there feel it talk to your
neighbor talk about it try to have an
open mind I want to give a shout out
these guys aren't even my sponsors but a
fat scooters they're friends of mine
they'll probably come back on board
sometime but they just sent me this
awesome freaking scooter so this is good
news I'm getting into good stuff this is
awesome scoot I'm telling you I left the
house I had them design it because I'm a
big warriors fan you know the movie the
Warriors old 70s movies and they decked
it out and it's just it's just amazing
and not only that but and you know they
don't want me to commend them but one of
my buddies my good friend Preston
Christensen Preston it's mom Michelle
and Chris I met them at the Ronald
McDonald House and Preston I've you've
heard me talk about is going through
chemo and he has cancer and he's an
unbelievable dude I love this guy so
creative so smart so awesome I love you
man
and they're like okay let's get him a
scooter they scan it sound my freaking
scooter so I brought it to him it's just
like that's you know they're really cool
guys at fat scooters and Peter and drew
thank you for that and Preston thanks
you and check out fat scooters comm
they're phenomenal and they didn't even
ask me to say anything I'm just saying
it because I love them and every time I
get out of the house and ride a scooter
people like where did you get that and
there you know the other guy is my good
friend Mike and he has this vodka called
Papa J's he's just a buddy and it's
amazing and let me just say something
about here is the here's a little bottle
I just want to give a little shout-out
to my good buddy
again not even sponsor just a good buddy
pop O'Jays vodka
yeah gave me a case of him [ __ ] if I'm
talking about Mike it's it's vodka it's
like vodka only different it's made out
of the nectar from the flowers of a
coconut tree
it delivers smooth crisp taste perfect
for cocktails or on the rocks a lot of
history there it's a great company you
need to check it out I mean it is it's
it's really amazing and they're going to
give you a coat here pop OJ's calm go to
pop OJ's
P a P o j s p a p oj s comm and look it
up and you know what you could have some
vodka sent to your house and use the
code rosy 25 for 25 bucks off shipping
so you should check that out pop OJ's
vodka I just love it I really do it's a
it's a no-brainer it's like you're at
the beach when you drink some of this
stuff what else can I tell you thank you
to my patrons you know I love you we
talk a lot we did a private youtube live
we do a lot of those where they request
songs and I play them and have these
chats it's pretty amazing and I just
really enjoy it it's my community my my
peeps over at inside of you on patreon
if you got a patron and you want to be a
patron join because a lot of people have
become friends and it's pretty awesome
and there's a bunch of extra stuff that
you get from you know if you like the
podcast you get a cool extra stuff and
also the other patreon I have is with
Jon Heder if you like horror movies and
that's called where have all the good
horror movies gone and Jon and I do that
and that is a blast
look into that we tell everybody we're
going to watch we watch it we talk about
it we have a rating system it's a lot of
fun so those two patrons that I really
freakin like also big thanks to omae's
and my friend Amy Malan raised a lot of
money here Tom Kristen and I from
Smallville we did this we raised a lot
of money for charity for the Ronald
McDonald House of LA and I'm really
proud of that and I'm happy and thank
you to everyone who donated everyone who
is just the sin of the podcast and
supporting my passion and you know thank
you
alright so someone who went to this
place proved a Swiss which will talk to
these amazing therapists in a moment but
first Zack Levi who I've talked to
before he got me to go to this place
he'd really get me I got myself a butch
he'll probably talk about but we're just
going to talk to him for a few minutes
he's so insightful and he's such an
advocate of mental health and he's so
open and honest which helped me be open
and honest and get my ass to a place
where they could help me a little bit so
Zach Levi thank you for coming on I know
you're just a big advocate for mental
health you you talk about it you're open
with it it's it's just great for people
listening you've been on the show twice
I know you're gonna interview my ass all
inside me but today is it's kind of
special because we're having a mental
health week and you know I know there
was a mental health month just passed
and I missed that I loved it and it's
it's safe to say we're you you and I
both went to the same place right oh
yeah yeah we went to a place quite
pretty swiss which you told me about
numerous times before I finally said all
right I'm going to do this and it did
change my life in many ways I mean and I
know it changed your life in many ways
so I I said you know I asked people that
I still talked to and that's Ellen and
Sandy behavioral therapist and a life
coach and sort of get an idea and
understanding about you know what they
think in this environment were in and
you know what did what did you get from
you know from going from just from your
experience to ultimately you know as
with any therapy it really just depends
on what you need theropods that you're
ultimately gonna get out of it right
like you and I could have both went to
the same place but both of us while we
might have some crossover in some of our
[Music]
you know reprogramming or or things that
we needed to be done in our lives we
might have had some similar issues we
sure we had very different ones as well
so what you take out of therapy is what
you bring into therapy and then decide
to work on in therapy and you know
ultimately what I took away from being a
pretty swiss was my own life back
i I didn't ultimately want to live which
led me there and then I left there very
much wanting to live and very much being
hopeful about what my life could be
after having been awakened to a lot of
not all you know because there's still a
lot of therapy for all of us to do
throughout our lives but awaken to a lot
of what my major malfunctions were and
where they were rooted
in my past in my family and my mother
specifically my stepfather how they
treated me my father not being around
for giving myself the empathy that you
build for yourself when you learn how to
do that and then how that then
translates the empathy you build for
your abusers because at the end of the
day and I think one of the biggest
revelations I took away from all of it
and when I continued to champion or try
to champion even now is people are doing
their best even the let's say
quote/unquote worst people in the world
are actually trying to do or think
they're doing their best given the world
that they were brought up in the
programming that they received the
reality that plays in their head through
their eyes through their ears you know
and we're all we're all just traumatized
all of us we don't realize it we've all
been told that you know traumas like
either massive physical trauma like a
brain injury or massive psychological
trauma like you went to war and you are
fighting in the trenches but what we now
know in modern psychology is that trauma
is a massive spectrum of very intense
moments that happen to us throughout our
lives subconscious child some people do
some people like if they hear somebody I
don't like yelling and you're like well
where did that come from not that
everybody likes yelling yeah
and we don't even really think to unpack
that in our life we just assume that
well that's just who I am and look
there's all kinds of parts of us that we
are I believe inherently deep down in us
in fact one of my biggest fears about
going to provide Swiss was or really any
kind of intensive therapy was that I was
afraid I was not gonna be me when I left
and nothing could be farther from the
truth not only was I me when I left
there I was a better and healthier and
stronger me I still had all the same
desires and passion that I had when I
went in there it was only amplified and
made more clear and more strong for me
to go and I think uh
approached and attacked the mission that
I think God has given me in my life and
what I want to go and accomplish in him
continuing to want to accomplish so I
took hope out of my time there I took
you know taking back again my own Worth
and life things that I didn't agree
I'm struggling with it and know that I
didn't love myself I didn't really
understand even the concept of self-love
I thought I did I think a lot of people
think they do I don't think most people
actually do if you love yourself you
don't speak ill of yourself you don't
chastise yourself you don't hate on
yourself you don't speak down to
yourself and I did that ad nauseam and I
didn't think twice about it and I did it
because my parents did and they did it
because their parents didn't they did
and great in that cycle is the hardest
thing in the world to acknowledge saying
this is this is wrong this is why this
doesn't work how do I change directions
and it's not easy and it's like you've
got like you said from the beginning of
this you got to want to do it what you
put into it is what you're gonna get out
I mean you cannot go in and are thinking
fix me I think that's the the notion of
everyone who believes that you look at
help and they're just gonna give you all
the answers the answers are there the
more you allow yourself to be vulnerable
and open at least for me
then I have a better chance of just
finding out what's causing certain
things that are going on in my life is
let's say a you know it's a spiritual
Christian ilk of sorts it's what I was I
grew up with and I've read my Bible you
know a good bit and I feel like so much
of the ethos that Jesus was talking
about or very much the things that are
ratified that are validated within
modern psychology meaning if you want to
live heaven on earth if you want to have
life abundant right now in your life
there are some very key things to
getting there and one of them is
forgiveness you have got
forgive yourself you have got to forgive
yourself you've got to forgive everyone
else in your life it'll kill you inside
it'll kill you thinking that there is
some there are there's some set of rules
that everyone has got to be following
and if you've been follow me I mean
that's one of the things that was
driving me crazy I thought I was
following the rules I thought I was
doing right I thought it was you know
doing what we're all supposed to do and
called to do like you know it's still
not that it still doesn't tick me off
sometimes when people drive like
[ __ ] but you know like my road rage
I would get so frustrated with people
that we're taking advantage and it would
cut in at the last second like you know
going over long I was just gonna say a
Laurel Canyon yeah I would grow and
because I hated that people were being
fair and they weren't they weren't
playing by the rules whatever the hell
rules I thought that we were supposed to
play by by the way everyone has a
different opinion kind of I mean we all
different countries have different rules
we there are some worlds but we all kind
of agree upon but I mean even those
aren't all entirely agreed upon right
and people all come from their own
backgrounds and their own traumas and
their own abuses and their own fears and
their own insecurities and we have got
to be able to look at the child I mean
this is modern psychology 101 its inner
child work it's its restorative healing
work that you need to do with your
five-year-old self really any age self
of yours but to in order to forgive
yourself and of grace with yourself and
love yourself and these are all age-old
tenants that people have been trying
like Jesus I've been trying to tell
people forever you know forever because
if you can do that if you can go do the
work on yourself to realize that it's
not your fault very there's some wonder
what Robin Williams says the Matt Damon
and Good Will Hunting
you know it's a passive powerful scene
and Robin Williams basically just saying
over and over again it's not your fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
makes me cry just thinking about I know
you know it that is the truth that is
the truth and if we can look at every
single person in this world through that
lens through luck through a lens of love
and compassion and grace and empathy and
forgiveness ourselves starting with
ourselves and then allowing that to go
out into the rest of the world if we can
genuinely care about every single person
know that they there they're acting out
their anger their frustrations their
look at what's going on in the world
right now
it's and it's all in and both sides of
this argument are looking at the other
side going villain evil monster instead
of saying hurts lost scared child of God
that's how we come together ultimately
you know we're all working progress and
you're always ordering progress and I
know that after privilege I know that
something happened dramatically in your
life and you got Shazam and it happened
and it's like you know and it's not
saying like hey go to a clinic and bulb
and then when you're done you're gonna
be that's not what it's about it's about
going to feel better - but not love
yourself learn how to be a better person
and I think you know I was just so lost
so thank you again I mean you really you
really you got me to go and they changed
my life I know I got me to go I did it
yeah you got you to go you you dance
around it you know you know sometime
with goodbye be like hey man tell me
about the place again we talked about it
but that's the thing like you know it's
a beautiful and still true to this day
adage you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make it drink nor should we
try to make anyone drink thank you for
this this is important and always I will
always be open and available to talk
about mental health and my love for you
I love you buddy let me talk to you soon
Zach Levi great dude I hope you like him
as much as I do let's I think we should
probably get into this we have two
guests today and they're gonna talk to
you about you know this is a world we
live in right now
that there's stress and anxiety in the
world before this and now this new kovat
thing and well it's not new now we've
been sitting in our ethnic houses for
quite some time but you know and then
you get the protests and all these
things it's a new level of anxiety and I
can't even imagine how a lot of people
feel who are really really into it
especially african-americans who are
dealing with this and you know I used to
think you know you know I want to relate
I can relate to you can watch this
documentary 13 years ago I called my
friend Chris McDonald crying Chris
remember that understood no one could
possibly understand it's true we can't
and all you could do is try to empathize
or sympathize or just try to understand
and just be a human being that's it
nothing else to be said just be a human
being I think that's uh well said
Rosenbaum probably not so today in the
show it's uh we haven't made we have
amazing guests we have a life coach
who's a lot more than a life coach
Ellen Wasel who I met at Prive a Swiss
when I went away obviously went away it
sounds so dramatic
executive and life coach at Prive Swiss
and executive coaching chief possibility
rien of the possibility experience I
love this quote she does she she didn't
create this quote Ellen you quoted
someone else but I'm gonna quote you who
quoted if you bring forth what is within
you what you bring forth will save you
if you do not bring forth what is within
you what you do not bring forth will
destroy you I like that a lot
then we're gonna talk to Sandi Danyel I
want to keep saying wonderful because
these women are wonderful changed my
life
licensed clinical social worker who
brings 25 years clinical experience and
a reputation is one of the top
dialectical behavioral therapy in
Connecticut
her resume is just ridiculous to both of
these ladies and they're gonna give you
some insight and and and I hope you'll
learn something I think you will on this
very special week of inside of you and
without further ado let's get inside
Ellen Wasel and Sandi Danyel it's my
part of you you're listening to inside
of you
with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience yeah my pants on its shorts I
am where I'm glad we started at that hey
you are light you are a life coach right
right so I think you know I could tell
you what's going on in my life whether
I'm wearing pants or not most of my
listeners would probably not be shocked
if I wasn't wearing pants I've seen some
in your Instagram have you yes so are
you thinking that therapy really didn't
pay off did it really did you know
that's that's the thing so Ellen Wasel
thank you so much for being here you
helped me so much at reveille Swiss and
I always you know I always think of you
we've talked we've kept in touch it's
just awesome to have you here and I
think the world needs this right now
it's this health week I call you know I
always say health is wealth and if
people could listen to a few people who
do this for a living and know what
they're doing and know what they're
saying then maybe they might get
something maybe they might get something
from this that's all I want is is to is
you're giving back I'm trying to give
back and thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you today that's what we say
on the show okay good so in a nutshell
life coach what does it mean to be a
life coach like if somebody said life
coach what does that mean what would you
say that means I'm always curious about
what's going on in your life right now
where are you and where do you want to
go right and and what's getting in the
way
what challenges what opportunities what
curiosities do you have what is it
that's blocking you from getting to
point A to point B and so it's all about
curiosity it's all about possibility
it's about really teasing Internet so
unlike therapy which has got a healing
agenda coaching has a development agenda
I want to help you get from point A to
point B okay well that makes perfect
sense but now I don't think in your
education maybe it did maybe it was one
of those things in there there was a
class called coronavirus pandemic that's
said okay we're gonna learn what to do
during a pandemic but now people might
how was a life coach gonna help me now
like right during all this ball I I'm
sure I could say why but you know why do
you think it's so important yeah so you
know this is it's unusual times right
we're not prepared for this
you know bad stuff happens in our lives
and and hopefully less of it then more
and you know usually we kind of figure
out how to get through it but the more
of it that it is and the more you know
grand-scale it is it's so overwhelming
right so it's like people just forget
it's like common sense people forget
what they need to do to get through and
maybe they've never done anything on
this scale before so it's about having
somebody kind of go through the journey
with you kind of share tips give you
some ideas ground you a little bit and
share some some real practical advice
about how to keep your wits about of
yourself right and take care of yourself
right well how do you what have you
noticed with clients that you're talking
to now doing this whole thing what have
you noticed the biggest issue is yeah
you know so every week it changes so
most people are in like week seven week
eight right now it depends on where you
are geographically and what's going on
in your in your local areas right but
you know I watched people really go
through the shock and awe the you know
trying to wrap their heads around what's
going on then there's just you know
every day is a new normal and trying to
make sense of that and then you know the
last couple weeks I really say it's
really been about grief right and it's
it's it's grief over what we're no
longer able to do you've got kids they
can't graduate from college you have
people that can't get married you have
you know people who are passing away and
you can't go through those rites of
passage of you burying your loved ones
you know so there was so much grief
so last week this conversation would
have been very different because I just
feel that it was that great epicenter of
grief this week I feel like people are
starting to really think about what
comes next I really feel like people are
starting to step into possibility
they're starting to curate curiosity
creativity and they're starting to think
a little bit more about okay what comes
next
right and so it's helping people like
holding that container for them to be in
that position of wonder and to start
thinking about maybe my kids are gonna
go back to school early maybe my
business is going to reopen maybe I
actually will have a paycheck again
right so people are starting to think
about what's possible for them so this
week has been very different than the
past weeks and and that has been the
reality of coronavirus people are on a
different curve of change and they're
they're grappling with the unknown and
kind of going through that mourning
process if you will so what do you do if
I said you know what do I do about the
unknown I'm a teacher and or let's say
I'm a you know I work at this local
business and it's closed so you know
what can I do what can I say it's a
difficult question because it's like you
know I have to make money and that's not
exactly you know the easiest you know
one has the answers exactly but I mean
how do you talk to someone that's just
you know dealing with that which are a
lot of America's a lot of people in the
world so I'm going to go back to the
word that you said is unknown how do I
deal with the unknown and you know that
kind of practical pragmatic is when did
you ever know right like how is it that
we've come to look at this as this
control we're needing to know what comes
next and when did we ever know so
there's been a predictability to our
lives you know you get up every day you
do your thing and you know unless
something tragic happens you know
there's a pretty good chance that your
day is gonna follow a normal penis but
we never really know okay so my first
thing is let's get real about not
knowing I know it's uncomfortable you're
not supposed to like this this is not
normal right so don't even try to be
comfortable with it don't try to like
this like it's okay to be really upset
uptight uneasy right now but you never
know you never know what the outcome of
something is so let's think about what
we can control right let's take your
power back so who do you want to be in
this right who do you want to be on the
other side of Karuna when this pandemic
quiets down what do you want to notice
about your life
who do you want to be as a result of
this right there's been so much time now
where people are they're isolated
they're connecting in different ways
they're reassessing things they're
getting back to simplicity like there's
a lot of cathartic moments where people
are starting to really think differently
about their lives and and to be honest
we're not going back to anything right
people say oh I just wanted to get back
to normal it's going to be a new normal
so I think you know a lot of people
really struggle with change and the
unknown and and that is the reality of
this and so what we can control is how
we show up who do we want to be right I
know you want to work I know you want to
make money oh you want to go back to
school I know you want to send your damn
kids back to school right like I get all
that what's within your control so it's
a day-by-day practice right and what
have you found that is something that
you have control of like what is it but
you sort of the advice you give to like
hey this is what you can do because
there's there's obviously you know
people always think I can't do this so
that's it without that I could so they
fall apart you start to see them to fall
apart obviously having a routine I would
assume that's what I always think right
absolutely I think right now the most
important thing is self-care right you
know thankfully so many of us are not on
the frontlines we're not healthcare
providers we're not you know first
responders right that's a totally
different response but for most of us
we're taking care of our family members
and ourselves and so self-care we've got
to take care of ourselves before we take
care of others so one of the first
things is to have a gratitude practice
to think about something positive right
what's good in your life starting your
day off with something that you can you
can hold this true right the sun's out
the grass is green you know different
things that kind of buoy you in the
morning kind of get you going right so
thinking positive right checking and
taking your own temperature on on mental
health how am I feeling today right like
checking it on yourself what what am i
habits am i eating too much am i
drinking too much am I not moving my
body
it's getting in my way right and then
being really clear about what join me
what connections do I need to create
right being isolated doesn't mean we
have to be alone right so how do we
connect differently and I've really seen
people who move through that process and
get really creative right but we have to
almost do that every every couple days
if not every day I you know there's
clients where I'll talk to them one week
they're great they've got this they big
plans in place they're doing great and
then three days later they fall yeah
well I think people you know especially
if you have a family you have putting
kids through school or whatever the
situation is your only job was a busboy
at a local restaurant and now it's like
you're waking up going well how do I
stay optimistic about this how do I you
know and it's all i'm guessing it's it
seems like the mind is the most
important thing like keeping your mind
strong i mean i you could all fall apart
if we allow ourselves to like you were
saying you were you know the routine the
you know it's like you said what are you
eating what are you drinking and i'll
tell you right now i so many freakin
excuses it but it's the pandemic i'm
gonna have pizza again and i'm gonna
have a soda at 10 o'clock with caffeine
i need to stop doing that and that's
what I'm seeing people right now right
you know it's like yeah we could be
doing all these amazing things to take
care of ourselves and we're not because
we're resisting wait wait we're a little
bit angry we're depressed we're anxious
were fearful right all of these things
do not allow us to take really good care
of ours it's like counterintuitive right
yeah so you know allowing yourself to
have the bad days when I say you know I
said to somebody earlier today you know
if you need to eat another pint of ice
cream like just do it right you're in
this cycle right now where you're still
really you know struggling with what's
going on and she named it she's like I'm
grieving I'm like then eat the ice cream
right on the other side of this a week a
day a month whatever it is you're gonna
be fine and that's what I'm telling
mostly you're gonna be fine we're gonna
be okay and
that brings me to another really
important things ask for help and be
willing to receive it right yeah whether
it's calling a friend calling a health
care professional that you've worked
with you know talking to a group or
community so many gyms and studios and
places that are that are usually filled
with community there they're making this
accessible online for free right so ask
for help let someone know you need
something and then be willing to receive
it it's okay to accept help yeah it's
not like there's one person going
through this there's millions and
millions of people around the world
going through it so obviously there's
different degrees of it there's you know
obviously go down to people who are
homeless when you thought things can get
worse it's worse there's there's all
levels but that's not to make your look
you know you don't make your level
insignificant because it's not as bad as
someone's it's still some it's it's a
change that you're not used to right
it's it's something that you and you
know no I think I think that's important
I think to understand that you're not
the only one going through this and
you're not alone I think we all feel
alone and we forget that hey everybody's
going through this some people are more
fortunate than others you know you know
what I learned from you is one of those
things were it's not like you told me
that you were pretty you're so
straightforward but it's it's things to
get rid of like okay I explain something
to you when you go okay I wish you could
listen to yourself just now explain that
because it sounded like all that at all
that is stress could you get rid of that
do you want to do that why would you
what is that
I'm like uh yeah but then I disappoint
other people that was always Armour what
I said to you and what is your response
always when you're like oh I don't want
to do that cuz it's so stressful and I
and I don't really I'm not enjoying it
as much and I'm doing all the work but I
don't want to disappoint someone how do
you respond to that how did you respond
to that like what is when we do these
things we we get into these habitual
loops where we've done something in the
same way forever right and and you stop
and you look at it and you ask yourself
what is this feeding in me what
thus serving me right the answer is
never anything good right torturing
ourselves beating ourselves up limiting
ourselves it's it's such a punishing
nature so I I always say what is the
cost of letting this go who are you
without that thought that activity that
that habit I mean yeah who are you
without that it's the power of no - it's
like when you really don't want to do
something learning how to just say no
say I'm not gonna do that because it's
it's gonna take time from the things
that I really want to focus on and
that's hard to sort of understand right
you and I think I do that's still in my
life where I have so many things and I'm
like you don't have to do all these
things in fact you're wasting so much
time with this that's not contributing
to your mental health or your physical
health or any part of your health so I
remember like looking at you and just
having these conversations with you
without you force like saying this is
what you need to do it was something
that you just you allowed me to really
take it all in and sure it took a couple
of weeks before I said I'm letting go of
this I'm letting go of this and I'm
gonna go this I think I called you Oh
two weeks after I got back home and I
said hey I got rid of this and I got rid
of this and I did this it made my life
easier it was just a weight off me it
just helped me so much and I think that
was I think that we tend to do that a
lot I think people want to make they
want to appease they want to I want them
to like me I don't want to disappoint
them I don't want somebody said to me oh
my god
like you you show up is the capital you
like yes to everything right now I was
like yeah I am right I was burned out I
was stressed out I was over committed
over-caffeinated right and I was like
wait why what am I saying yes to
everything how is that even possible I
mean and so it's it's discernment its
energy management it's time management's
resource management like we only get so
much of those things right and if you
give it all away what's left right
you're exhausted
exhausted exhaust and when you let some
of those things go lose friendships
I don't lose friendships I didn't I was
I think that's a thing to how you handle
things right just saying I love you I
this is too much for me and I know that
you'll understand because you care about
my well-being and if they don't then
that person was never that important to
you really at all anyway it comes down
to we don't need to ask for permission
or give justifications for our decisions
right like if we choose to give some
context it's out of out of respect but
we're not required to right just a
simple no I'm not able to thank you for
thinking we know Thanks right like we
don't have to go into these long
drawn-out diatribes as to why we did or
didn't do something and that's what we
tend to do yep then we end up saying yes
anyway cuz we kind of convinced
ourselves in them and the conversation
that I should just do it like just don't
do that thing
treat yourself up and I think that's
what's going to happen honestly for a
lot of people as a result of this
pandemic we're going to get much more
clear about how we want to spend our
time how we want to work who we want to
spend our time with you know the quality
of connections you know all of this it's
just this discernment as we start to
turn the lights back on and we start to
do this differently I think we're going
to make really good choices for us I'll
keep you by the way this right here I
think is the most profound this is the
most important thing we're talking about
and I didn't know how we got there but
we got there and that's all that matters
because I don't have you very long but
you know when this all ends life will
change things will be different but now
I think we've had so much insight into
you know isolation and being alone and
you really have had a lot of time and
may have some more time to think about
what is important in our lives right is
that what you're saying that Watson
that's not important get it get it the
hell out of there it's just such a
trickle-down effect right you know so
think about these companies where
thousands and thousands of employees
have been working at home right how many
of them need to come back
what if there's different ways of
working but if there's death of you know
educating our children like here in the
in the Northeast there's never an excuse
for a snow day ever again I'm sorry like
I feel bad for those poor little kids
because who doesn't love a snow day but
we know how to do online learning now
right
we know it's winter we can have a lesson
plan ready like these kids never have to
have a snow day which means you don't go
to school until July like you actually
get your summer back because you didn't
chew it up on snow days right like we
are learning how to be resilient how do
you use our resources and to be creative
so that life can keep going on it all of
this is an opportunity to do things
differently that's absolutely right
we've had so much time I think all the
time you know we waste all day I have
friends that like I just when I thought
I'm wasting my time I'm like get off
your video game get off your [ __ ]
couch what are you doing and it's just
like wow that's I'm not I can't do that
I can't waste my whole life I this is we
have so much time what am I gonna do and
I was nervous about this I know it
sounds pretty stupid but like for
instance how many of you podcasts I just
go in and I talking to a Mike and Ryan
does it all and he uploads everything
and I'm like well if I want to do
something I love and I think that helps
people and I love it helps me I am gonna
do this and you know and you know I have
to sit there and go okay well I gotta
learn this camera and I got a focus on
an inanimate object and I gotta make
sure it's in focus on both cameras I got
to make sure this is recording and I got
a dis a whole soundboard and I got a
record and I gotta upload you on this
thing and I and I'm like you know what
Wow
I could do that now that is really cool
that I could do that
and I wasn't expecting good hey I'm just
the [ __ ] talent here Ellen I don't
need a bucket but you know what I can do
it and that's it's just it's it's
fulfilling it's it's it's something that
take this time people are gonna go I'm
gonna learn how to play guitar hey I'm
gonna do you know I don't like my job
and I know I'm not working right now so
let's take online classes let's do
something else so I could start applying
for things when they come out that I
could do something else this is the time
that you've always asked for it too if
you think about it people voice to God
if I just said you have so much time all
right look that's the choice how do we
want to use this time how do we want to
use this to our benefit and who do we
want to be on the on on on the flipside
of that's right yeah so much possibility
right as a possibility what do I say I
believe that everything that I always
have anything that happens in my
everything is either a gift or an
opportunity for a new possibility right
this is just like with hospitals Amen
sister I'm gonna ask you a couple
questions from my patrons who are
amazing and support the podcast Mary for
the life coach I'm a child of the 60s in
in my 60s and I'm going through an
identity crisis my husband of 37 years
died in 2018-2019 I had a double
mastectomy then she said discovered
Smallville I was on chemo but that's
another story Mary I've been teaching
since 1988
I've been mrs. broke up for more than
half my life but now I'm sort of being
pushed into retirement I don't know who
all be if I'm not mrs. broke up anymore
most of my friends acquaintances really
and even my therapists are related to
the school where I teach I don't have
anyone to complain to I put on a happy
face because of the crisis I've lost my
classroom which has been my refuge
refuge and and being forced to learn new
technology which confuses me
sounds pitiful when I when I say that
inside of you has become very important
to me and Michael Rosenbaum makes me
smile thank you um so what would you say
to someone like Mary that's a real tough
I mean that's a law changed a lot of
disruption right and so I think that's
where really digging deep to see you
know what are those opportunities to
maybe ease into that technology a little
bit and think about what she wants to do
with it
right like there's it's something that
makes her uncomfortable and that's my
first clue anything that kind of makes
us a little uncomfortable is an
opportunity to grow right she's
stretching herself a little bit so it
might feel a little scary a little
foreign
but you know that's the perfect
opportunity maybe lean in in the safety
of the environment that she's in like
she can't fail it right and that's where
you can ask for help you know whether
it's you know a neighbor or one of her
girlfriends children or like young kids
know everything about technology and so
there's an opportunity to maybe get on a
Skype resume and talk through some
things and share the computer a little
bit just like get a little bit more
familiar with it and for [ __ ] sake
Mary you're in your sixties you're not
in your nineties I love you lady I mean
I know you but come on you're not old
just you know and just you said it you
said it though you said go at your own
pace take your time with it don't get
overwhelmed because that's I do you have
to do this I'm overwhelmed I'm gonna
push it away I'm gonna push it away just
slowly get in there and start getting
dirty and you'll find out huh I figured
that out and that will give you enough
confidence to maybe figure the next
thing out I mean it's all about doing
man and we never we all do the same
thing we all wait and crafts in it we
can't do it we can't do it but most of
us we can do it she's a little
technology she can do it yeah Angelina
Gonzales in my late 20s and I feel very
stuck in my life right now I have a
degree in photography but it's not my
passion honestly I don't know what my
passion is yet and I want to do more
with my life than just get up go to work
repeat but I feel like I'm too old to
start over ie go back to school
considering I have rent billing blah
blah blah I feel like this is a young
person's world not a you're almost 30 we
want you what
world I'm very discouraged day I'm not
knocking I'm just saying I'm a lot older
than you what steps her advice would you
give to someone in that position you
know somehow she got in to cut into
photography and now she's doubting that
that's her passion right so okay that's
good make peace with that and be
creative and explore if you don't know
what you're good at or what you're
passionate about ask your friends right
ask them what do you think I'd be good
at be amazed by what people will tell
you because people who know
you see the light in you right they see
these how you show up how you talk about
something what you get excited about
they often see something before you do I
and so just have the courage to make
peace with okay so it's not photography
and go back to school for God's sakes
like who says you can't go back to
school after a certain age right like
people do that all the time sometimes
they have to write they lose their jobs
and and and they've got to go reinvent
themselves like that that is the fabric
of being human we're constantly evolving
and changing and challenging ourselves
right so don't be afraid of school right
I believe that purpose is a multi
horizon right there's you have many
different horizons of purpose it's all a
collective build so something that she's
done with photography everything she's
done up into this point in life will
prepared her for what comes next
just trust the process yeah I think it
was you who said something to me it was
like you know just because you are good
at something or it's what makes you
money it doesn't mean I'm trying to
remember exactly what she said but it
was like you know like it doesn't mean
you have to do it because everybody else
thinks you should do it oh well you're
good at that and you make money at that
so this is what you should do but I'm
like well do it that's hard if that's
your moneymaker but you don't exactly
love something
if you bring what's within you forward
it'll save your life if you don't bring
what is within you it'll kill you Oh
like we have a purpose everyone has a
purpose I don't know one time somebody I
was working with somebody and they said
their therapist told him they had no
purpose
I was like wait whoa everyone has a
purpose you just might not know what it
is right now maybe your purpose is to
figure out your purpose like allow
yourself to be okay with that like
exploring it right like we all have a
purpose and so you know if you're doing
something that's not fulfilling start to
explore right see how what you're doing
can bleed into another area you don't
have to quit you don't have to you know
go on this big epic journey to find
yourself but allow yourself the
permission to explore what else it is
that excites you what do you what do you
love about your job what is it that
because I know you did something else
corporate thing and you know there was a
day where you know I'm not gonna tell
you about your life but there's a day
you just said that not gonna do that
anymore something you made a lot of
money in something you could whatever I
remember because it made me feel like oh
she's opening up in a way that I could
relate to and and you what was it cause
you didn't know you're gonna be
successful as a life coach right I mean
you probably here's the thing there was
a repeating pattern right I'll ask
people what's your wound what do people
say to you right and so there was this
word that kept coming up right you're an
awesome listener right you're like I sat
down in your office and it was like I
took truth serum I just out came
something I didn't prepare to say to you
right and so I was like oh my nickname
as a kid was tabby my grandmother named
me that because I was curious like a cat
like always asking always inquiring
right and so I think I've been a coach
mine you know I know I've been a coach
my entire life I just didn't know that's
what I was meant to be right and so what
do I love about it it's meeting people
like you it's changing lives
I have been doing this since 2012 and I
still have clients from 2012 that will
reach out and say hey just want to let
you know what's going on in my life
or no hey want you to know I just
achieved that thing and that is like the
most amazing thing I think like I know
what I do matters like I I help people
find their truth like it's all inside of
you I didn't tell you anything I didn't
ask you to do anything I didn't make you
do anything I just was there for part of
the journey asking really good questions
and helping you see it differently right
right like what an amazing privilege to
be part of somebody's journey secret
what was the quote you just gave a few
minutes ago or is about if you're not if
it's something inside of you is not
leading the way was it if you bring
what's within you forward it'll save you
right so it's talking about your part
right right there but if you don't bring
what is within you forward it will kill
you okay it's like knowing you were born
to do something but you didn't give
yourself the opportunity knowing that
you really want to try this thing like
just you always wanted to be this thing
but you just don't have the courage or
maybe somebody can support you or when
you've got self-doubt like that will eat
you alive right it's like if there's
something that's within you that you
feel passionate about you've got an
explorer you've got a lot about Ellen
Wasel you are a you're a gem you really
are I love this and I hope I know people
will get something from this and I just
can't thank you enough you know we'll be
in touch and I hope you'll come back
sometime absolutely this is a joy thanks
for allowing to be inside of you Ellen
okay that's that that's the show I love
you thanks so much and Saadi is brought
to you by fair harbor i think you know
by now that I love these guys I have 10
pairs of shorts and I wear them every
day not 10 pairs but I do wear two at a
times not too at the same time you know
what I'm talking about
I love these shorts this isn't me just
trying to sell you something this is me
saying you're gonna love these shorts I
guarantee you and it's also Father's Day
is coming up and this is a unique gift
you know you die they go to the beach
whatever you in the pool that doesn't
want to chafe I hate to talk about that
in front of you but if your dad's like
me or any other guy he doesn't want to
chafe that's why you go with this lining
weights he feel this lining I just want
you to try it all fair harbors products
are made from recycled plastics to date
fair Harbor has recycled over 2.5
million plastic bottles keeping plastic
out of waterways and off the beaches
fair Harbor makes products for you to
enjoy the places you love while
protecting those places at the same time
20% off everyone listening right now
you hear that head over to fair harbor
clothing calm and use the code inside 20
for 20% off that's inside 20 and say
goodbye to mesh lining forever I hope
you really enjoyed that Ellen is a
fantastic woman and you just got to see
this like the tip of the iceberg it's
just like just the tip you just seen a
little bit of all the genius and a
little more genius coming your way
let's get inside behavioural therapist
therapist of mine I love you let's get
inside sandy Danielle I'm surprised that
you are you know you're willing to do
this because you know I it's mental
health is so important and I always say
health is wealth
that's it doesn't matter how rich you
are we all have one thing in common and
that's you know health is a number of
number-one thing that we have to sort of
we have to take care of ourselves and
you know I mean and so first of all tell
me about what is DBT is a philosophy in
school created by a lady named Marshall
and a ham who herself had some mental
health challenges and quite honestly she
found that when she had been a recipient
of mental health services that it didn't
quite do it for her they wanted to do
more medications it was more the
traditional medical model and having the
schools of thought such as cognitive
behavior therapy which are super
successful along with her her idea to
really bring in Eastern
to meditation you know kind of getting
quiet within oneself reflection and then
some basic skills training about how to
manage your life how to manage your
feelings how to manage people right make
it worse right because I wanted you to
describe it because you know I could do
that but you know all I could say is it
works and you know you use a combination
of a lot of great therapies right you
don't believe in one and I think as an
actor it's like I you know you learn all
these things ago Stanislavski and people
oh I studied with Lee Strasberg and
that's what I believe I'm like great but
I like to believe in like I take things
from everywhere well Strasburg had this
cool thing in Stanislavski had this cool
thing and who - Hagen had this and is
that sort of what you do exactly what
because everybody has something to offer
in some wisdom when it comes to
providing somebody there's a lot of so I
think you kind of I think it is in the
best interest of your patience and in
your clients if you're able to be
flexible adaptable like that yeah I
didn't know what to expect when you
first met me you know and I guess my
personality I'm sort of all over the
place and I was like you know do you
remember me out saying I don't think I
could be helped I just feel like there's
so much and I don't know where to begin
do you get that a lot from people or
they like I'm just so complex like we
had this theory everybody thinks oh well
my problems are too much for you to
handle do you hear that a lot and I
think that's one commonality that we
have to lean into versus what makes us
different from others and that's a whole
that's a whole part of willingness of
being in treatment is being willing to
join your comrades or your peers who are
also trying to find their way in life
and not separate yourself so much and
kind of come at it from like people
could never understand that's a great
way to resist treatment is just to say I
can't be helped so I'm gonna just do my
thing you know I'll say look
try it with me that's true and I think
resistance is the biggest problem we
resist it and I think nowadays isn't
mental health being more normalized and
in society than it was absolutely
embracing and you know I've always said
to people come into my office and worry
more about the people who don't go to
therapy than the people that did yeah
because you go to therapy you're willing
to be self-aware know thyself and kind
of take responsibility right and mean
we're not responsible for traumas that
necessarily happen to us but we are
responsible for being healed and getting
better and not letting those traumas
dominate our life and that is the true
challenge you know does trauma does loss
this deprivation become one's identity
is that the life that you want to create
yeah yeah you've and I think you know
especially with the pandemic the
coronavirus and all these things that
are happening in the world is changing
it is and and hopefully for the better
with all this crap that's going on you
hope that the you know all the divisive
nough split eclis and all this stuff
it's like you know just forget about
that let's try to connect let's try to
you know it's so easy to say but yeah I
had the feeling that once it's all over
and I'm sure I'm a cynic but did we go
back to the same way it was and or do we
really create this environment where we
we own it and we're lucky we're so lucky
to have the connection and be able to
have the freedom to do the things we do
and we should take advantage of that and
not sort of you know people are always
on the phones people always you know
it's just there's this disconnect it's
really fractured Society and it's
testing us you know how do you do when
you're all alone how do you do when you
sit with yourself what do you think
about where does your mind go you know
do you catastrophize and kind of think
about worst-case scenarios and how does
that impact your mood and then how does
that then affect your behavior so it's
sort of this painful day-to-day
self-awareness of you know what is it
about
that's working what is it about myself
that's not working so good we all do
that yeah I mean people think and think
and think and think all day long and
that is I think what a lot of people are
struggling with right now no
distractions
yeah quiet who are you who am i that's
that's the big question you sent me this
list which was really helpful when I
read it a few times of just things that
you know people think about and they do
when and just it was just sort of a
simple guide if you will and one of the
things that struck me as you said you
know people and I do I'm gonna be honest
with you I had a cigarette I had a
cigarette right before this yeah I know
and I have I know I know
I was I've been stressing a little bit
I've been dealing with it I've been
trying to get it in a routine and when I
do I noticed like today I had so much
anxiety and I said I don't know what
kind I want to lie in bed I went on a
bit and I remember what you told me
early on you said what is that doing
lying in bed is it helping you like no I
just sit there and anxiety and you're
like get up do something and I
remembered that and I got up and I went
downstairs and I just started lifting
weights and getting my blood going and
went for a walk and the anxiety just
started to go away
it was it's not SOT I mean it is science
it's just it's it's amazing how if you
just go and do something because you
could get so caught up in your your
anxiety in your world that you almost
start to feel sorry for yourself or I
forgot how you talked about that to me
but yeah careful which ones you're gonna
invest with and run with and the
strongest emotion tends to get the most
attention so if you're worried you're
the natural mind inclination is going to
be to look for the situations that
validate the emotion right so because we
want to be right it's just human nature
but we have to challenge ourselves not
to sit in the sadness not to sit in the
sorrow not to sit in the loss
just because we're feeling it doesn't
mean that we need to react to it or do
anything with it
it's a feeling feelings come and go they
give us important information I'm not
saying
discount them but we don't need to set
up camp there if it's ineffective and
it's it's a barrier right oh I don't
feel like it well you're not gonna feel
like it this is telling one of my
clients of their dad I said you know hey
I care for you deeply but how you feel
right now is irrelevant you need to do
what you need to do and I know that
sounds strange coming from a therapist
you will not always be motivated but you
do need to get discipline yeah figure
out what works and what's better and
what is effective well you said
something like you know people using the
pandemic as a reason for engaging in
self-destructive behaviors drinking
during the day going back to
relationships they maybe that maybe
toxis engaging in things that they
normally wouldn't do and it's it's just
I think that's human nature it's like oh
let's go back to a place that you think
is safe but you know is not good for you
it's like why are we doing these things
and then you get mad at yourself and
there's a cyclical thing that goes round
and round here I go again doing the same
[ __ ] what's wrong with me right now
right look do not give yourself too
interest permission we don't look back
we're not going that way okay you have a
lot of time to think right now
can we lean into what we would like
versus what we had versus how we feel
what do you want to create how do you
want to feel what are the things getting
in the way of that I think it's super
important that we hold ourselves
accountable and being mindful of where
our head is going and be actively
working to avoid avoidable suffering
okay not to reengage not to use these as
this time as an excuse to really go down
yes you don't have work but that does
not mean you should go and start
drinking during the day right well
especially if things were going
relatively well if you're getting your
things together and all of a sudden this
happens you're like oh it's the end of
the world I could have a smoke I could
have a drink you're just gonna fall back
into those bad habits and you know one
thing the thing that resonates with me
is when I was there while I was there at
Prive you know it's 21 days - I've
talked about this 21 days to break a
habit right well then I assume it's 21
days to create
good habits correct 21 but like really I
mean if you really they say 90 meetings
in 90 days and they say those things
because the more time under your belt
the better but yeah that's three weeks
to start or sure right so simple things
I wake up in the morning and let's say
it's what any listener that's out there
they wake up and they have anxiety well
what do you recommend they do first
thing what are what are some of the
coping skills what are some of the
things that you would say well hey good
morning here we are I don't know why I'm
feeling anxiety maybe a little bit of
self reflection but I got to get up and
get going I'm not going to entertain it
that much I'm not going to feed the
beast I'm feeling a little unsettled
today so let me go ahead and keep my
normalcy as much as possible for my
anxiety sufferers routine is huge okay
staying in a routine staying in some
level of structure uncertainty is one of
the few things we can do right now so
you need to do that you don't sit there
and lay and think about oh my god what
if this gets worse right we don't want
to create the emergency we want to
respond to the feeling so I'm having a
lot of discomfort I'm not sure what's
going on today we want to speak on it
and then we want to get busy and active
now that could be whether you're hitting
the gym or that could be doing your
meditation for the day you know pick
however you want to then begin your day
but the feeling should not be the
dominant factor in why you do it
okay feelings are super important but
let's be honest some of them are skewed
they're based in trauma responses
they're based in our perception so not
always accurate yeah and if we live very
emotionally we tend to live more
impulsively and impulse sometimes
creates a lot of regret emotions don't
make sense sometimes we don't know why
so you know what I would say is that
sticking to your normal senior routine
will be of most benefit to you because
that is what you can control we don't
need to sit there and dissect every
feeling in every thought you feel how
you feel maybe you watched you know at
SVU last night
people will say like you need to get to
the bottom but you know anxiety when
people come in my office and they tell
me they're anxious it tells me they care
very much which is a beautiful thing and
that they think a lot yeah and I help
them figure out if they're part of the
solution or part of it yeah I think
that's been an ongoing thing with me is
you know thinking too much worrying too
much
stressing too much I mean talk about
sleep disorder I was starting to sleep
really well for months and months and I
had things and I don't know if it's
subconsciously with this whole thing
going on I don't know what it is maybe
you could tell me but I'm having
problems sleeping staying asleep waking
up feeling rested and I'm like what am I
doing wrong I'm doing the same things
aren't I and then you look back and
you're not exactly doing the right
things you're drinking sodas early I
don't know it's challenging for me to
get my 11,000 steps in a day right now
I'm walking laps in my backyard you're
trying to create that same level of
activity just so I do have a healthy
ability to try to sleep that evening but
I do think we're all sort of in a stated
state of hyper vigilance and this is
such a bizarre time in the world I mean
I never remember growing up not trusting
like if the news was accurate or you
know I never remember this stuff being
even contemplated and now we're very
much suspect of many things in our world
and even just the way the pandemic is
gone right every States doing it
different right well what the heck that
mean you know that's the anxiety
position you know Florida isn't doing it
the way Connecticut's doing it you know
I got to get on board here and we're all
sort of responsible for ourselves and I
think people are feeling kind of hung
out there like oh my gosh this is
unprecedented and there's so much news
there's so much going on with whatever
side you're on if there shouldn't be any
sides at this point there should just be
scientists say things and those things
are real so anybody who says anything
else
is not real that's if you're a scientist
for instance if you think you know a lot
about therapy but you're not you didn't
go to school and study to be a therapist
why would anyone want to listen to you
if I was talking to you and you were my
sister people would be saying writing
and saying um I think your sister needs
their they shouldn't be talking about
therapy about the facts ok facts and
evidence is how we need to kind of move
forward we don't want to live in what if
what shoulda coulda woulda if only so we
want to live in what the facts are
I tell people look I don't want you on
the media all day long with CNN in the
background I get a couple places you get
your news from that's it are you saying
maybe in the morning get somebody the
source that you like and then at night
try it again but don't all day go into
this because it's just gonna make you
anxious we can do our part ok but we
don't need to suffer every moment of
every day in order for us to care about
something for us to feel that it's
important for us to be somewhat
frightened about it right you want to
give yourself some mental respite
because the supply runs dry after a
while you have to refill you have to
rejuvenate you have to refresh you have
to step away right for some reason I
didn't ask I have this patreon account
so my patrons you know they asked
questions and I was oh [ __ ] because this
was sort of spur of the moment with you
guys and I was like oh you know I want
to do this I don't have a Mental Health
Week but there were some questions and
Patricia says as so many of us deal with
the repercussions of negative mental
programming from our childhood hmm hello
or past relationships what is the best
way to reprogram mental self-image to
embrace our essential self and begin to
identify and live our best lives
awesome question right first of all I
want to know what her narrative is about
that time in her life the story we tell
ourselves is huge ok and there's a lot
of different ways to look at how a
person
and what they got you know what's the
difference between the kid who succeeds
on from the same impoverished
circumstances from the kid who doesn't
it's their mindset it's how they tell
themselves their story it's their
ability to kind of say well that was one
chapter and what is the good that comes
out of adversity a lot okay does that
mean we liked to go through it and that
we shouldn't hold people accountable of
course not but we don't want to live
there we're so much more than those
moments and when we're children and we
go through trauma we tend to get stuck
in those moments and still respond as an
adult in many ways like that so it's
super important that yes you acknowledge
where you come from you don't forget
your humble beginnings but as you grow
and as you age and as life changes it's
important to look at that narrative and
come up with different insights right
we've gotten some difficult memories
that we want to be mindful of but we
don't want to sit and view the rest of
our life from that purple perspective or
happiness will be very hard to find part
of your story when you say part of your
story part of my story I mean we well
what do you notice like look III I'm
open you know I'm open about these
things so I give you permission but what
did you notice like you saw a
transformation if you were like of you
know when I walked in that room and then
we started having a couple sessions a
week and we started talking about things
and the more I was open what did you
notice that I was stuck on do you
remember kind of what I was always stuck
on what I always all the time right what
if my physical health changes and I'm
not able to do something that I would
like to do right what if I can't feel
better what if I way we got with this
anxiety forever right it's a lot of
projecting into the future and what I
found really helpful was just to help
bring you back to where you're at now
and how much you've been able to do
and try not to get too far ahead of
yourself you know there's a lot of
wisdom in one stuff at a time as
simplistic as that phrase is we can't
possibly prepare for every possible
scenario well there are some things
we're going to have to cross that bridge
when we get there and you don't need to
grieve and react and respond and prepare
for the pain okay
yeah so choose yeah it so it's almost
like you're you're living what am i you
know somebody said you know if you stand
up and you look down at the ground you
have one foot in the past one foot in
the future and you're pissing on the
present it's kind of true cuz it the
past is depression right anxiety is
there for is the future you're thinking
ahead
I don't know right it's a lot of lack of
self belief a lot of lack of hope and it
also can come from when people who you
thought would be there couldn't be there
if that if your people couldn't do that
for you it really kind of makes you
rethink the whole idea of being able to
trust the world right but where I think
we grow is when we realize look we have
to look at our parents and as a parent
now I so see this hopefully I'm not
damaging my children every day that
passes but you know have to take a look
at what part of our past do we want to
bring along how do we take what happened
to us and make it wisdom versus
continuing acting it out so like going
back to Patricia's you know question I'm
having anxiety okay I don't know why all
right what do you want to do something I
gotta get out of bed I don't want to sit
here in this like for yourself you know
you grew up you took care of yourself so
it's hard when you're sort of a lone
soldier to let people back in and know
that right so you had to retests with
that and you had to believe that you
became who you are yeah and I also think
that for me uh you know and a lot of
people out there one of the biggest
things for me is is letting go if you
could just forgive it's not that you
have to forget
it's not that you have to you know
that's what I learned with you it's like
you can forgive because if you don't
what happens it just keeps lingering
around right it makes you feel sad
it put you in more of a victim stance
you know and you want to be able to take
these difficulties and make them into a
positive part of your story for the best
that you can because it wasn't because
you weren't a good enough kid that you
didn't get what you didn't get it was
because caregivers weren't able to
provide it or whatever reason when way
or the other so sort of T you know when
we get hurt when we're little we always
carry that and it's super important as
adults to be like wait a minute okay
that was what you thought when you were
eight all right there was no good reason
for you to get the heck you know beat
out of your whatever when you were eight
years old for doing something that was
really benign okay that was kind of
outlandish so you don't want to carry
all those false beliefs and falsehoods
that it was always your fault and I
think therapy can really help people
kind of untangle that well yeah it's all
you go to therapy and you're like oh I'm
fixed it's your do you have to do a lot
of the work like you guide me and you're
like this is what you you know this is
what you need to do and you don't tell
me what to do as much as you let me sort
of figure out we talk about things and
then you make it so much more
understanding for me where I can go Oh
like would you remember this is
something where you're like when you
start to think of something that hasn't
happened you say stop stop stop
that hasn't happened that's two weeks
from now we're not gonna spend our time
on this right now that was something
that really for a while after I left I
would people probably look at me about
it stop no [ __ ] not yet you sir not you
sir but stop and then I could do it my
mind I'm like stop it dude this isn't in
a week and a half
you're not gonna worry you can set time
you said you can set time another day
four to 15 minutes and you can think
about that if you want but you are not
wasting your time and getting anxious
for two weeks until that happens
when you don't know what's gonna happen
you're gonna be fine and it's like it's
these little things like that look
there's a lot of common sense in therapy
to that we can't grieve or commit to
feeling about things in the future we
just don't know what's gonna be and we
don't know how they'll respond and by
the time that comes you have no idea
what situation you'll be in and you can
absolutely handle it in a magnificent
way yeah it's keeping busy it's not
allowing yourself to get overwhelmed
it's all right Vanessa in the sky says
I've been dealing with depression lately
since my dad passed away sorry Vanessa I
am a lot better now but I'm still not
enough everything kind of triggers me
still so my question is are there
techniques or thought processes I can
follow to not let everything get into my
brain so much I feel like no matter what
someone says lately I take it too
personal and will fall back into a deep
dark pit of depression that I'm trying
trying to climb out of
you see we lose a parent at any age we
feel like an orphan okay so you're
feeling a little bit more exposed you
don't have somebody that's been in your
life for as long as you've lived and
maybe there's some element of loss of
feeling protected in the world and
feeling safe and secure and as you
continue to live your life and with each
day that you're able to accomplish
things and go to work or do those
responsibilities you will start to gain
the confidence in yourself again that
you have always had all along that maybe
you attributed to that was because of my
dad was here your dad taught you well
okay and he's coming up and I think
that's a beautiful thing and I think you
should honor his memory you know I
always say to my clients if my kids
remember the day I die I'm gonna be so
pissed because there's so much I'm
trying to do for them while I'm living
right and I think a lot of parents like
don't concentrate on the date
concentrate on the life he lived and the
lessons he tried to teach you and how is
he still within you
and is he popping into your head cause
it's trying to give you a sign cuz
you're dating a guy that's not good for
you I don't know okay but there's a lot
of reasons why you're thinking about him
and some of it might be circumstance
situational it's not a bad don't push it
on what you love - yeah I I think that's
that's profoundly wise you know as you
know I lost my grandfather who's my best
friend
in November on Thanksgiving and si got
me a little emotional and you know sandy
sometimes I get emotionally a little
choked up and I just read you know when
I was reading her letter I get you know
I started thinking about her and I get
it like you know it's it's it's
difficult and I you know I remember at
the end I just I didn't even want to see
my grandfather he had Alzheimer's was
late stage and I was like you know III
he was then we went to a hospice and
they're like do you want to see him I'm
like no he knows how much I loved him I
know people can do what they want and
some people have to see and my uncle had
to see him and people I did not want to
do that I go I Irv knows more than
anything that I loved him and loved him
and that's something that I think to
that to know that Irv you know whoever
you lose they loved you you never get to
say what you want to say it's almost
like there's never enough time but you
have to know that you know I was loved
he knows that I loved him and there was
no I never looked back on that I didn't
want to see him like that that was just
me yeah everybody grieves differently
everybody has their own ways remember
that okay that's not going to be helpful
for you when you think about or you want
to think about the loving memories yeah
in a great cup that's exactly right
we don't want to think about what he
looked like on his deathbed because that
will break your heart and the human mind
is this funny way of like not knowing
sometimes whether it's happening now or
whether remembering something in the
past and what you end up doing is Ratana
tossing yourself sometimes again one of
these notes here you said and I'm gonna
let you go here in a second and I hope
you come back because it's just you have
so much information and you just there's
something about you and that's why a
good
therapist is so important to find it's
because and for us it's an emotional
connection I just feel safe with you
I just feel safe I feel like I'm not
being judged and I feel like a lot of
guys a lot of whatever it is you know
they don't wanna go to therapy because
you know they're afraid they're gonna be
judged I don't want to cry crying snot
for man I've never seen my dad cried
never saw my grandfather or car I think
once but so what would you say to people
out there who have always said I'm not
going to therapy I'm not gonna therapy
have been putting it off what would you
say to someone what are you you know
what how bad could it really be and if
you think it's as bad it's probably not
as bad as most and I mean unless you're
harboring something like he killed
someone
you know for god forbid but like we all
have our [ __ ] you'd be surprised at the
[ __ ] that sandy hears there's a game for
every behavior right so if you're
holding on to stuff and you kind of have
that barrier and maybe you're just not
comfortable because maybe there's been
some bad therapist out there that you
you've had bad experiences with therapy
is for you it's for you to evolve for
you to try and figure out what your best
life would look like nobody's there to
strip you down or to be standing in
judgment
you know like when people come to pre
they're all I was so nervous you know
they might say something to that effect
and I said look where else are you gonna
go where you have some of the brightest
minds who want to share with you their
insights about how the great life you
need could even be better that's a gift
to give yourself there's just some stuff
in your head sometimes that doesn't make
sense
and it's really helpful first of all
just to tell the story but also for the
story to be heard and first the you know
you know me I'm very authentic I'm like
really there's got to be everybody has
so everybody has something remember that
everybody out there everybody has
something that's another thing it's like
you know I try not to judge anymore I
mean I do I mean we all judge in some
way but it's like you know especially
after all this is just like do you just
love each other respect each other fine
time to call someone because it might
make them smile spend an extra five
minutes with someone instead of you know
I can be very selfish I could be doing
things but sometimes I'm just like you
know what you're gonna spend today
calling all the people that you really
do love and you're gonna tell them and
you're gonna talk to them and you're
gonna see how they're doing and that
doesn't take a lot of time and you know
getting with this pandemic and
everybody's you know the anxiety and all
these things um you said you know
watching inspirational speakers helps
try to keep close to your time schedule
so you won't feel so rundown when it's
time to reintegrate people explain that
real quick yes so I continue to get as
much as it may pain me because I'm doing
that because I want to keep my sense of
normalcy and I know this is temporary
and when I go back to work I don't want
to suffer and I want to make sure I stay
on schedule and it's actually good for
me to get up and work out early and get
that stuff done remember we don't want
to give ourselves permission to just
fall apart here and be a hot mess we
have to figure out you know and stick to
our morals stick to our values stick to
our priorities and do what's in our best
interest even if we may not be feeling
like it because if it feels like things
are so chaotic right now but don't add
to the chaos well look by the way I
didn't bring up all your education all
these things because that will be in the
intro no but people should know that
this that you just know like he didn't
even say no you went to Yale you you've
written a book you've you have so much
education and so much wisdom and I know
it firsthand by by talking to you and
you working with me and I could not be
more appreciative that you came on today
and I don't know why but I like I feel
like you know when you get like a little
emotional like it's behind your face
like it's like just like I don't know I
think just because I haven't been
talking to you as often as we were and I
think you know it makes me feel like did
this worked I think I think that's what
it is it's like this worked why aren't
you looking at this woman weekly you
know what I mean and it just kind of
makes me go do let's go
you know and I think another thing you
taught me was stopping so hard on
yourself
like I'm not gonna sit here and go you
know you can talk to Sandy for a month
okay you didn't so so start [ __ ]
talking to her you know out there you're
listening you're like oh you know what I
haven't been doing well didn't do it
stop saying oh and be so sad about what
you haven't done and just do it turn it
around and I think that's what we all
have to do and we don't want to make
people into professional patients we
want them to live and succeed in love
outside of our office but you know we
can feel some good voids to where some
of those needs didn't get that and it is
a privilege to be on one team and to
help you well thank you Sandi Danyel for
allowing me to be inside of you today on
inside of you of Michael Rosenbaum
that's kind of a saying we say at the
end of each job so it wasn't promoted it
sounds perverted but this has been
awesome I love you to death and I hope
some people learn something today I
think they will like this yeah time to
reach out alright I will thank you guys
for listening today I hope this helps
you know it's when you have a someone
that has so much knowledge about you
know these topics and anxiety or
depression or whatever it is or you know
getting your [ __ ] together you know
twenty minutes thirty minutes isn't
gonna do it but it can give you an
understanding hopefully and just an idea
that hey maybe this will work cuz not
maybe it will it will work you just got
a you got to commit so I'm gonna thank
my guests I want to thank Ellen Wasel I
want to thank Sandi Danyel from the
bottom of my heart for doing this they
didn't have to they're so busy and
helping other people I'm gonna read you
a little fan letter apropos comes to
mind it just is it's very fitting for
this episode Rosie and one of your
episodes you mentioned the Wellness
Center you went to in Connecticut can
you share the name today you proved a
Swiss thank you for your great podcast
it's so helpful to hear you and your
guests be so open KB well KB you're very
very welcome I'll tell you that much
also reminder
about patreon the inside of your patreon
join it if you want and where have all
the good horror movies gone patreon is
pretty fun but Jon Heder and I only
talked about horror movies and watch
them and it's a big community
all right calling out all my patrons
here it is inside of your patrons thanks
for the love I couldn't do this podcast
without you period at the end you leave
the who knows maybe I'll leave
how do you like that you know who you
are Nancy D Mary bee Leah s Tricia F
CeraVe Yukiko Jill E Brian H when uh
Lauren G Nikko P berry L Angelina G
Jerry W Kevin R Emily K Bob be Robert be
Jason W Kristen K not Kristin Kreuk a
cooler
Allison L Raj Raj Sean W Joshua D Emily
s CJ p Samantha M Hamza Hamza be
Jennifer n Stacy L Carly T Reem Jennifer
s Jenelle be Tabitha 272 Kimberly
Melissa see Mike EJ cameras and Judah D
Ramiro Beth be Chris F Sarah F Chad W
Lee Anne P Darla darling
Jackie P Rodrigo s Rodrigo s Rachel 77
hi ray ay Maya P Megan D Demario
Jennifer see Maddie ass Tiffany L
Kendrick F Ashley F Kelly W Marg V M
Sigourney P Thomas T I love you guys all
you know it's funny I'd love to say your
last things but that might take forever
I don't know maybe we'll do that next
time say your names and then everybody's
looking you up and you lose your privacy
and you try to hate me
all right there Azzurro my patrons thank
you for all the love
and guys be safe and love one another
it's it's so simple thank you for
allowing to be inside of you thank you
for taking the time to be with me and
it's pretty it's pretty awesome that you
guys listen to the show it's uh it's
just cool that alone is just cool if
anybody listens to you so I hope you got
something from today I like to say did
it for you but I did it for me too I
wanted to connect with these therapists
and even Zack and hopefully help help
someone they helped one person that
makes me happy so all right much love
[Music]